here you sit about 12 years after you
did too fast and the appetite for these
movies is stronger and stronger than
it's ever been before how does that feel
as an actor um you know it's as it makes
me proud you know it makes us all proud
to know that we're working on something
that people are still interested in
we're working on something that people
are still excited about it's it's family
it's adrenaline it's there's a DNA as a
furious facet of here is DNA and the
writers and producers and executives at
Universal along with us as the actors
and people that are involved in this we
have figured out a DNA and we're running
with this thing and
you know naturally with what happened
with our brother and Paul I think as
many movies as we've all done I felt
like this is the first time we tapped
into the sensitivities around how to
make this special because this is art
this is Paul's art this is his fiber
this is his DNA and we wanted to make
sure that it felt like a graduation it
felt like a beautiful send off and we
had to protect all of that asset of the
equity this is you know this he could
have been working on any other movie as
his last movie this is the movie that he
was working on this is the movie that
put Brian O'Connor and Paul Walker on
the map and we had to protect that and
we did and I think of all things we know
that this is not about any of us none of
us wanted to do this press junket none
of us want to go do red carpets and do
all of that hey go see the movie but
we're doing it on behalf of Paul and we
know that the world is gonna be very
very proud of how we protect it Brian
O'Connor and Paul and to send this out
there
it's just beautiful you have a lot to be
proud of all of you
youtube I am um watching Roman grow all
these years and develop an arc and
change what's that been like for you you
enjoy that process you know I I think
I'm very grateful to john singleton um
my first movie was baby boy my second
movie ever was too fast too furious and
and John said to me we're gonna make
sure that the world knows you're funny
and that has been a blueprint that we've
been able to hold on to for all of these
movies and I'm not a comedian and so I
think the way we play it is we play as
serious and then we have all of these
intense guys with muscles and deep
voices and all of this these intense
scenes and so my character along with
Chris Ludacris and tej were able to like
find funny moments and moments that
otherwise may be very intense and over
the top and serious so and you know what
we found in this one
is that because of the obvious what
happened with our brother and our family
the funny in this movie means that much
more because it gives the audience a
moment to finally ah you know so we're
excited I mean every fan around the
world we just know that it's not about
money it's not about a call sheet it's
about um making making the world proud
because you can go out and support any
movie the fact that y'all keep showing
up the support the fast and furious we
hope to always make you proud um Roman
probably says it best when he says first
you give us we have alt then we have a
tank then we have to shoot a plane down
now we have drones and play cars falling
out of planes can you talk about the
scope and the scale of this one listen
I'm waiting on a phone call to tell me
for fast eight we want you to bungee
jump and shoot the villain on the way
down like I don't know what the hell is
on the way next but you know what it
just I feel like it's like a
relationship the worst thing you can do
is create routine if you're married for
ten years you want to keep your wife
guessing you want to keep her wondering
what are you gonna do next what you're
gonna say next what's on the way and you
don't ever want to get caught up in a
routine
so it's just beautiful I know how much
fun you had an Abu Dhabi but can you
talk about what it meant to the
franchise to bring the film there and
why it was so special well I think I
think one of the most unspoken reasons
that this movie is this franchise is
successful is because we have you know
redefined the standard of Hollywood you
know supposedly a multi-ethnic movie on
this scale wouldn't translate and we
have we have changed that perception and
so being is that the Arabs and the
Muslims around the world continue to
support this franchise just as a culture
who are we to not embrace that and have
the presence of that energy and that
culture to be a part of this movie in a
major way and
it was a very proud moment for me
because I went to Dubai you know to
bring in my 35th birthday and I finally
found my smile and
that level of love and culture and
authenticity is something very special
and i was just very happy when i found
out that we were going to Abu Dhabi to
incorporate the spirit and energy of the
culture in the franchise it's gonna be a
very proud moment on april third
especially everything that we all went
through on a very personal level to get
through it and it's gonna make a big
statement I feel and Paul is with us
every day I'm probably gonna be wearing
this sweater for the next five days um
because uh
it's not about any of us so that's it
you